I have a very complicated relationship
with death as a medical student I've
learned about death I've been with
patients as they've died and I can even
talk about death after all I did title
my talk let's talk about death but in my
heart I don't accept death
I find it excruciating death just seems
so unfair
so out of my control so final ever since
I was little I've had this horrible fear
that I would die and not have a chance
to say goodbye after my grandmother
passed away when I was 13 I started
writing a ton of notes to everyone I
knew to say goodbye with the idea that
maybe somehow they would be sent out in
the event that I met an unexpected end I
pictured death by lightning I was a
pretty dramatic child but I figured if I
couldn't control death then at the very
least I could try to make sure that my
final actions were according to what I
valued making sure that the people I
love feel loved now fast forward to my
training at the hospital I'd like to
tell you about a patient let's call him
Sam Sam was fantastic he was 78 years
old he had a huge family and he loved
telling me stories about his old surfing
days Sam had cancer and kidney disease
and blood clots he could no longer move
on his own when I met Sam he had been
brought in to the hospital by an
ambulance with internal bleeding Sam was
in a lot of pain but even despite that
every time I would walk into his room he
would look at me and say hey baby how
you doing
grandpa still had game unfortunately
though his situation quickly became
worse as his medical team we decided to
broach the topic of death we asked him
what would you want Sam in case your
heart stops beating or you stopped
breathing Sam would have nothing of it
Sam got angry and his family got angry
and frankly I got pretty angry at the
situation - but we had reached medicines
limits Sam ultimately went home with no
plan he ended up coming back several
times to the hospital until he finally
passed away at the hospital in a cold
sterile environment surrounded by
machines I've often wondered what would
Sam's final year have looked like how do
you tried hospice Hospice is a service
for the dying which optimizes for
comfort and symptom management rather
than focusing on trying to find one more
cure the research tells us that for
folks who try hospice they often live
longer and more peaceful lives than
those who don't I don't know what Sam
would have wanted we never talked about
death but what I do know is that Sam had
never thought about death and that's the
case for for most of us and what that
means is that when we get to the point
where we can more or less anticipate
death the time that we have left becomes
more about death and less about life by
show of hand how many of us are
uncomfortable talking or planning for
death me too
we don't think about death we don't talk
about death we don't plan for death so
I'd like to challenge us all today to
change our conversation to change our
culture to include death because when we
plan for a meaningful death not only do
we die better but we also live better so
before we move on I'd like to lay out a
few basic facts to put us all on the
same page number one until Google comes
up with a cure we're all going to die
number two god forbid that somebody
actually gets struck by lightning but
the majority of us will die of terminal
illness or old age so let's focus on the
latter two and number three there's no
wrong choice when it comes to how you
want to spend the end of life but
oftentimes it is a choice modern
medicine has made tremendous advances
but it's also convinced us that maybe we
can cure death we can't so instead the
conversation becomes how do we want to
die we spend our whole lives planning
for our milestones writing our
narratives planning for that big job or
the wedding or even a low-key notes
talk but yet the final chapter still
sneaks up on us in the u.s. most of us
don't die the way we want to while the
majority of elderly folks have indicated
that they'd like to die at home only 25%
actually do in medicine our default is
to throw a ton of interventions at you
in an effort to prolong life but that
often comes at the cost of quality time
and spending your last time perhaps the
way you want the details of why we die
are different for everyone but if we set
our goals ahead of time then our doctors
can help us figure out which
interventions will help us meet those
goals I'd like to tell you about a
community and La Crosse Wisconsin they
it's a town in which they had a huge
widespread initiative to get everyone to
write their advanced
or the documents which you can specify
what you want at the end of life they
change their culture they change their
conversation they even change their
healthcare system to adjust to the need
and the result 96% of people had an
advanced directive on file when they
died and most people tried to most
people wanted to die at home and that's
how they died on their own terms for me
the most important reason why I care so
deeply about this is because of the
impact that it could have on my family
when we specify how we want to die when
we set our wishes forth we take the
burden of choice away from our families
the research tells us that those who
have a plan in place their families
suffer less stress less anxiety less
depression and they're free to breathe
rather than second-guess their judgement
planning for death will never take away
grief grief is inevitable but
second-guessing is not so let's change
our conversation let's think about death
let's plan for death let's talk about
death step 1
thinking about death in medicine were
taught to ask several questions when we
start off an end-of-life discussion
questions such as what matters most to
you what are your hopes what are your
goals and what are you willing to trade
off for them you might recognize these
questions as the very same ones that we
use when we think about life in fact the
career office has given us a fantastic
resource to help guide this that bet
you'll never look at that the same way
again
step2 talk about death sit down with
your parents your grandparents your
friends anybody ask them how do they
want to die and tell them what you want
as the Business School has taught us
maybe role play it out first and you
know we won't know all of the details
but if we paint the broad strokes early
then we'll be able to fill in those
details better later again there are a
few good resources that can help guide
this so check out the conversation
project death with dinner or read Atul
Gawande book being mortal and finally
step 3 write your advance directives
change them over time and tell your
family your friends and and and your
doctors about this and even if you don't
write an advance directive at the very
least make sure that you designate a
proxy and everyone knows about it
planning for death will never take away
the pain of loss the pain of losing
someone who's close to us and not having
them with us anymore I'm not sure that
I'll ever be okay with death I'll never
stop missing my grandma or Sam or the
countless other people whose hands I've
had the privilege of holding but I
believe that if we plan for a meaningful
death we can die the way that we lived
on our own terms because life is so
precious so let's talk about death
because I'm planning for a meaningful
death we allow ourselves to lead a
meaningful life